[Musique]
les meilleurs connaisseurs du terrain ce
sont les élus locaux et où l'état fait
une erreur c'est effectivement de ne pas
assez les solliciter de ne passer les
écoute et de ne pas assez leur faire
confiance de ne pas leur donner plus de
moyens parce que le tissu rural le tissu
du terrain ce sont les élus qui le
connaissent bien c'est sûr les élus qui
le font vivre et donc sur tous les
sujets aujourd'hui poignant on voit bien
que les élus ne sont pas écoutés et la
question de la fermeture des classes
reste un vrai sujet parce que l'école
restera toujours un marqueur de vitalité
des territoires ruraux on revient que
ces territoires connaissent une nouvelle
vie est une vraie reconstruction du
monde rural grâce aux élus qu'ils
trouvent des solutions pour faire venir
la fille plus vite pour maintenir des
commerces pour réinventer des services
et donc faut leur donner les moyens leur
faire confiance maintenir les classes
retrouver des professionnels de santé
des territoires ruraux vivront c'est ce
que veulent les habitants de pays
[Musique]